I'm going to call this method to be
approach to be because it says something
in common with this namely I'm still
going to got everything on one side so
I'm gonna get up everything in my
inequality on one side to have a zero on
the other side but then instead of
multiplying by the square
I'm just gonna leave it a rational
function so watch let's have a go at
this right I'm starting my first line
again right three over X plus 2 is less
than or equal to X let's do together on
one side again so I've got 3x plus 2
minus X just like I had before now this
time oh I should I shouldn't make
everything so I'm trying to go above the
answers so so far nothing is different
from the previous approach okay but
instead of multiplying through by a
square and making this a cubic problem
okay I just want this thing to be one
function right so that I can then sort
of graph it work with it all that kind
of thing but I don't want to x squared
so here's what I'll do instead I have a
denominator just leave it as a
denominator and I'll make it a common
denominator between these two things
okay so if I want to add this to this
I'm gonna have to multiply both things
by X plus 2 okay so I'm gonna have this
on this okay
happy time so far all good so remember
the reason why I didn't have to multiply
by a square is because I didn't actually
multiply both sides of the equation by
anything I just changed the denominator
of this term which means it appeared on
anywhere okay now let's expand the topic
and you should be getting this awful
sense of deja vu right now because
you're like I've seen this I've seen
this so many times what is it it's gonna
be X plus 3 X minus 1 right we've seen
this already
now why does this
keep on coming up again and again not a
[ __ ]
thank you okay it's gonna have the same
factors no matter which way you slice it
and move it around because the solutions
are gonna be the same
so therefore the factors are gonna be
the same can you see the connection it's
not arbitrary alright so this is what I
was getting at before Nikita if
whichever approach you get these numbers
end up or fall there will be all for
whichever route you take okay because
whichever route you take you'll end up
with the same factor well okay so then
the question becomes what does this
thing look like so when is it greater
than or equal to zero okay now it's
still a hyperbola but it's a bit of a
funky hyperbola different so that's how
we do this okay now I'm gonna give you a
bit of an approach for how to graph
rational functions in general okay it's
a bit of a longer kind of explanation
and it's sort of peripheral to akita
politics like this is the main focus
okay but I'm kind of digressing because
you will see these okay my approach is
an acronym phase very old-fashioned word
because it's coming taking sort of
multiple readings throughout history now
we really mean one meeting which is like
things equal that's all I mean by it
look bad but they're actually using
something else nobody else no way some
people still easy
like a funfair it's not quite what I was
thinking um very very old-fashioned
meaningful fair is uh is well it's sort
of to do with schema collide but it
means it means painful so something is
fair it's it's attractive right so I
want your grafts to be fair so we're
going to use you're not that kind of you
um some of these this is my approach all
right very conveniently the letters
stand for factorize find your asymptotes
find read descents and then do some
shading of regions okay once you do all
of those you can graph very easily
any rational function I throw you even
ones where you know this has got a
linear denominator which are kinda like
the easiest type of rational functions
but if you've got a quadratic there or
QB there any combination all right let's
have a go factorize that's easy
we've done that already you need the
numerator and the denominator factorize
here you didn't have to do it
denominator but just in case you get a
on a square down here or a cubic down
you using still fast Rises
that's the first step okay then you have
to fat factorize and find your
asymptotes by a factorization now there
are three kinds of asymptotes that we've
met before
okay but they're really only two what's
the one that we've looked at already in
this question X comma negative two right
this gives us a vertical asymptote so
vertical asymptotes are one kind of
asymptote there where the function just
can't exist full stop but then there are
these other two clients of asymptotes
either horizontal asymptotes which
received modes in them right or they're
more messed up complicated cousin
oblique asymptotes okay
so let me show you it's important that
we mentioned it because this one this
one
one big with the occasion
remember I said vertical asymptotes are
about where the function can't exist
right that that means that's equivalent
to domain class internal horizontal and
oblique asymptotes even though they're
also asymptotes they come from a
completely different reality which is
your function here just your function
what is it do we add its extremities
what is it doing it negative infinity
and what is it doing positive infinity
okay that's all it tells you about right
this is very important let me just throw
out this down I'll just give you a quick
example right there is a graph for the
equation I think it's x squared plus x1x
something like that it's not complicated
but it looks like this it's a pretty
neat looking function okay
I just look at it with me for a second
okay doesn't have any very positive does
it have any vertical asymptotes what
does a vertical asymptote me it's a
place where the function can't exist
okay just look at it tonight it's got
arrows on it okay now be careful here
depending on the actual function you get
there might be a hollow circle there a
place where it can exist but but it's
not an asymptote it's not a vertical
asymptote it doesn't do it doesn't do
this it's not approaching it and getting
closer and closer forever but never
getting there it just it just goes
clearing right through it stops existing
further in a while
and then just gives you it's not an
asymptote okay not vertical aiming but
there is
okay well according to the way I've
drawn it corny way I've drawn it okay
according the way I've drawn it okay but
all of a second look what happens in the
middle there right I actually can't
cross the function where just blows
right through okay you got this
horizontal asymptote which apparently
you can get closer to and never touch
and then like you forget that I don't
care you know I'm just gonna I'm gonna
be that good I mean the hips top of the
asymptote well I'm just gonna go
straight through his two main streets
now what's my point we say a center as
if you approach and you never get there
okay the horizontal and oblique
asymptotes
only have that behavior at their
extremities at negative infinity and
positive infinity the horizontal public
answers have nothing to do with the
middle of your function see they don't
tell you anything right look I'm going
away from the acetone I don't give a rip
words what it's telling me only over
here so horizontal turn of the
asymptotes you work them out in a
completely different way from how you
work out vertical ones right vertical
ones you just look at your denominator
right you say look copy there sir
negative to each example yeah
it's a horizontal asset sir absolutely
but it only tells the function what to
do at the extremities so it's actually
kind of misleading that we draw it in
the middle
because that has no effect on the
function in the middle okay it's only at
the end okay now like I said this is how
you work out a vertical asymptote but if
horizontal and oblique asymptotes are
about what's happening at really really
negative values and really really
positive values the simplest way to work
out what they're doing is by putting
really really positive values or really
really negative values into your
function and see what happens okay now
let's let's look at simple examples
let's look at this guy this is one of X
okay one so when you put astronomically
large numbers into X a hundred a
thousand ten thousand ten million okay
what's happening to this whole thing
it's getting tiny right now more
specifically than it's getting tiny
right I would say as X approaches
infinity 1 on X approaches zero okay now
just note by the way this is a zero with
a plus on it because I'm approaching
zero from a direction namely from above
it's gonna be zero point one 0.01 0.001
I'm always above them always bombers now
as I go off in the other direction
something differents happening as X
approaches negative infinity 1 on X is
still approaching zero but it's coming
from another side right it's coming from
underneath oopsie
all of these guys is gonna be negative
so you have a zero with a negative sign
of it okay all right now that's that's
the way you do it what happens here
happens here when you put in really
large numbers now you can know right
away it's not going to approach some
nice neat number because think about it
the reason this is approaching a nice
date number is because the denominator
overpowers if you like it overpowers the
numerator whatever the numerator is the
denominator will get bigger so that's
one approaches here but it doesn't
happen here does it the denominator is
getting bigger but the numerator will
always outrun it
right because you have a quadratic here
degree two and you've got a linear
function here degree one okay so I'm
going to approach as X approaches
infinity right
our function let's call it f of X it's
also important for you that's not very
useful okay
it's a project in E but but how is it
approaching me it doesn't tell us
anything right and if for example I
changed this I'd made that a plus right
would it still approach infinity yes but
would it do exactly the same thing no
because it's a different function so
what you have to do is and I'll get into
more detail with this later I'm not
gonna I don't to get held up like you
have to do some division of polynomials
here that's it that's a division there
right this divided by that okay
eventually you'll discover in this
particular case that what you're going
toward is y equals x okay now could be
something else it could be y equals x
plus 1 or y equals 2x I'll dig into that
another time and when you look at
rational functions in more detail I'll
give you a shortcut version as to why
though before we wrote the rational
function like this okay where did this
come from it came from all the way up
here let's see that look at this line
carefully with me as X approaches
infinity what happens to this
that guy there that guy approaches zero
right then this guy is so no that's okay
this guy just keeps on machi along at
the same rate but X's right that's what
our impression is so just play a my next
member with me if suppose I made that
two minutes what would it be approaching
as X approaches infinity it would be
approaching 2x right because this thing
is vanishing away right let me play
another - memory what if I change if I
change this number instead of three
suppose I had 300 in there what
difference would it make
answer when I go to infinity no
difference doesn't care about 300
infinity laughs in the face of 300 like
hahaha oh you're 300 I'm infinity right
so this guy's still vanishing off to
zero so that's a shortcut way of showing
you all I'll show you what far away
later okay stay with me we factorized we
worked out the asymptotes okay now I
want some intercepts
what are you intercepts of this thing
how do you find the intercepts there's
two kinds right there's an x-intercept
and there's a winder so I can tell you
right now now I've got a and x intercept
at negative three right an x intercept
at one somewhere over here and then
there should be a y-intercept how do I
find y slappy an x equals zero into this
and the easiest place to find that I
guess would be here yeah cuz I got zero
there that's easy - three all on 0 plus
2 that's negative 1 and 1/2 huh is that
number seem familiar
negative good okay so now I've done
intercepts okay last step and in some
senses this is the reader step that's
the most useful okay he's all gonna put
three now okay if you have a pacer this
part works to be hard on if you have a
pencil this will be easier I use Pacers
usually soon I'm in the larger I've got
a whiteboard marker so that's the
equipment of the pastry in this case
what I need to put onto here this is my
last step is these three factors see
this is one of the reasons why I
factorize not just to find the
asymptotes intercepts but also to find
out where I go positive and negative
these are the regions I'm going to draw
okay so watch again X plus 3 X minus 1
and X plus 2 each one of these is a line
each there's three straight lines that
make up this function so I'm very
quickly gonna draw them in very lightly
in pencil okay
so X plus three conveniently actually
not comedians I quit since it all goes
through there okay goes to X minus one
conveniently because dude okay and X
plus two conveniently goes through here
right where the young asymptote
all right now they do a thought
experiment you okay I forgive you these
two numbers okay
let's just multiply them they get 2
times 3 is negative 6
okay how about negative 2 times negative
3 6 right okay now just suppose you
didn't know that they were two or three
anymore it was just a negative number
times a positive number even though you
don't know the magnitudes or should I
say absolute values of these numbers you
do have this signs right so even though
you don't know if it's negative 6 you
know it's gonna be negative something
yes okay now have a look at this one
right I've got two negatives now even
though you won't know that magnitude
the odds on the absolute value have
known that the sign of what you get at
the end would be positive because two
negatives now have a look at mckeil I
actually I'll do one more
what if I divide it what if I divide it
it's the same isn't it because actually
division is just multiplication in
disguise it's just a different kind of
application now have a look at my green
lines these are my factors here right
what a good day boy these are my factors
so over here on this side I've got three
negative factors three negative factors
so when I put them all together what
will their product question be what side
we need right because if I three
negatives two of them will cancel out
and one will be left so he's there where
are we gonna do a bit of shading down
here I'm below the axis okay say it
again over here I've got all three of my
factors being negative
yes so I put three [ __ ] together if I
put together odd number of negatives
I'll still be near okay now I'm gonna
cross over a little bit in between these
two spots here from negative 3 all the
way over to negative 2 what are the
signs of my factors all the way around
negative negative positive ok so when
I've got two negatives in a positive
what's the result it's a positive isn't
it now you can start to see is a bit of
packing you you can stop thinking about
it in fact because I got negative then I
go positive and then I've gotta go
negative on all the way from negative 2
to the next factor all the way in here
I've got 2 positives and a negative so
of course I will be negative
okay last one now over here positive
positive positive
the net result positive okay so done
regions all right that's it now we're
ready to draw a pretty line so they will
tell you to draw regions but they will
tell you to draw accurately you'll need
to match up where it's going to go
through so much
I'm gonna use my asymptotes here as kind
of like my guidelines right
unfortunately I need to enjoy misfit
vigor but that's a can work river right
how about look to the left of the
asymptote here look at the features that
I don't I know that I'd be positive here
that's an intercept right and then I'm
gonna be negative and then I'm gonna
approach this guy yes so this is the
line I draw okay I know it's a bit
straight because of the scale that I
chose but there is a bit of a curvature
to it in here I'm going upwards and here
I'm going toward this asymptote data
right have a look to the righty acetone
what am I gonna do I'm gonna do the same
thing but reverse right I've got a bit
below the axis here which makes sense
coming on the edges up there I got
another we just said there and then I'm
gonna push this asymptote right so I'm
going through like so you can kind of
see the symmetry I've done the best I
can to meet all the features that I've
got okay so there's my graph
why is it like a Cupid oh you mean you
made this you mean that is how are you
talking about oh oh you mean my kiss
yeah yeah I'm just trying to make my
points that I've already put in so if I
had done this in pencil right I would
have maybe adjusted this a little bit so
that I could just clearly go through
okay
I wouldn't prefer to a drawing something
like that but I couldn't meet the points
that I've put in before okay there you
go
so all of that to say now I have graphed
this thing okay now I didn't have to
graph it in full detail to be able to
answer this question but you will have
to be able to graph these things later
on so that's why I thought I'd show you
all in one here
okay now let's answer the original
question when's this team positive okay
in fact we've already done it by this
step you see that okay I just want to
know when this thing's positive right
from here to here there it is yeah
that's okay
and from here all the way across just
like we expected from our other two
approaches okay so do you need to graph
the whole thing in order to answer the
question no but two things number one
you need to be able to cut these things
eventually number two being able to see
what the actual shape of this thing
looks like helps you to see like how did
we graph this default look it was a
cubic does this cubic not look familiar
which color my knees I'll use black
right
how does this graph relate to that one
it's got the same factors so it'll have
the same regions it's going to look like
this
it's kind of the same graph but a
different version of course it has to
have the same regions because they all
came from the same thing they all have
the same solutions